Speaker 1: Let's go back to the phones, which
are no longer phones. We now take calls via
discord. At David Pakman dot com slash discord
and hear from a few more people. Why don't we
go to Moni from the United Kingdom from where I
have just returned. Moni, welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Hi. How was your trip to the UK?
Did you actually go to Britain in the end?
Speaker 1: I did not. I ended
up going to Bath in the end.
Speaker 4: Oh, okay. Still a nice place.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Quite interesting. And,
you know, the weather was very shaky. I actually
I had an insane situation where I was walking near
kind of near Regent's Park in London, and it
was so windy that my hotel umbrella reversed.
Have you've seen an umbrella reverse, Right.
Speaker 4: Oh, like every couple of weeks. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I saw my umbrella reversed
and it was I was trying to hold on to the baby
stroller and the umbrella reversal was dragging
me around. And these British girls walked by and
were laughing hysterically. And I mean, but then.
Speaker 4: They should. I was saying, you know,
they should help you.
Speaker 1: They should have helped me. I
know they said beautiful day for a walk. That was
their joke as I was all right. Wrestling to try to
keep the stroller and the umbrella under control.
Speaker 4: Funny you should say that the weather
here is awesome today.
Speaker 1: Yeah,
I saw that the day I left. It got better.
But anyway, what can I do for you, sir?
Speaker 4: I just want to call in and say that in
the last few, I believe it's been a few weeks now,
maybe even month. Have do you agree that I think
that this is possibly the biggest movement for gun
control in the US that I've seen really since the
the while they ended the 2425 assault weapons ban.
I have never seen uproar like this coming out of
I think it was the state of Tennessee, wasn't it?
Speaker 1: You know, it was I want to feel the
same way you're feeling mony, which is, wow,
look at this is we've never seen momentum like
this before. It seems inevitable that something's
going to be done. But every time we think that
we're so disappointed, like after the Sandy
Hook shooting about 11 years ago, it was like,
wow, we're going to pass universal background
checks. It's just going to happen. And of course
it didn't. And you can go all the way back to the
civil rights movement of the sixties and seventies
and the assassinations of Martin Luther King and
Robert F Kennedy when there were fewer guns in
circulation. And it was like, wow, we're going
to see change. And we did get the Gun Control
Act of 1968 regulating the sale of firearms. And
then we went on to have 400 million guns enter
society in the United States. So I just am so
cynical that we're really going to see change.
I want to see it. And I hope that you're right.
Speaker 4: Yeah, me too, man. Is It's a bit crazy
over there. We all see it. It really is. The other
thing I wanted to say, if I do have the time, of
course. Yeah, I hope I do. Yeah. Is that with all
these issues that are going on recently with,
like, the whole thing of the Democrats planning
to, of course, pot on the ballot, supposedly
that they are pro-abortion rights and all
of the things we've seen from Donald Trump or
nothing we've seen from Ron DeSantis currently
abandoning Florida while it's under water, do
you think that a lot less people are going to
vote Republican in this next coming election?
Speaker 1: Now, when you say that fewer people
will vote Republican, do you mean that
some historical Republican voters will
vote for a Democrat or that many
Republicans will just stay home?
Speaker 4: Well, I don't really.
Speaker 1: I don't know the answer
to that. I mean, I do I do think that if Trump
is the nominee, which is looking quite likely
based on today's polling, I do think that there
is a contingent of the Republicans that are just
so sick and tired of the insanity of Trump
now under indictment, potentially with more
indictments coming, that they're going to throw
their hands up, some of them, and say, listen,
I'm not voting for a Democrat, but I'm sick
of this Trump crap. I'm just staying home. I
do think there will be a contingent like that.
Whether it will influence the results in any
significant way, it's just so early to say.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I agree. I had a friend from
Georgia who voted Republican most of his life.
He actually switched in 2022 because of the oh
interest and the abortion rights stuff. So yeah,
we will see. Oh, I'll not take up any more of your
time now, but thanks for answering my questions.
Speaker 1: All right. Money from the UK.
Speaker 4: Good day, you two.
Speaker 1: Great to hear from
you. Absolutely. Fantastic stuff. Let's
go next to Louis from New Brunswick. Louis
From New Brunswick. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. So good to speak with
you. Thanks for taking the call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 4: Got a couple of questions I noticed on
your show. Could have been a couple of days ago.
You mentioned that you're leasing a Tesla, so
there's more like a financial question. Do you
generally recommend that people lease vehicles?
I heard it's a bad financial decision overall.
Speaker 1: No, I recommend that people study
the issue on their own and make their own
decision based on how they tend to deal with
vehicles in their lives. Leasing makes sense
for some people in very specific situations. One
of the things about leases is that they can be
fully tax deductible as a business expense
depending on the use of the vehicle and how
it's structured. And that is like a savings
of whatever your effective tax rate is,
which can be a significant savings if you tend to
replace your vehicle with some frequency. Leasing
can be a much simpler path than trying to sell
a vehicle every few years, which you might be
underwater on if you're financing it. And then you
have to deal with repairs or whatever. Like I like
after three years being able to just walk away.
For me in particular, I mean, I'll be honest,
I've said before, I'm, you know, former Tesla
shareholder, Tesla driver, the the build quality
of my Tesla is not exactly something to write
home about and it's been in the shop a bunch
of times. And quite frankly I wouldn't want to
own it. Like there's a particular reason with my
Tesla. I don't want to own the thing. I want to
be able to just walk away and it'll be Elon Musk
or someone else's problem at the end of three
years and that by then there will be so many
other electric vehicles and the quality will
likely have improved. And the range that I'll sort
of have, like my pick of the litter is my, is my
hope. So for, for very specific reasons, leasing
made sense for me, but that doesn't mean that
it makes sense for any other particular person.
Speaker 4: Got you. Thank you for the
detailed response. All right. One more
question if we have time. Sure. Do you think
there's any chance that facing the the threat
or like high possibility of imprisonment,
that Donald Trump will flee the country?
Speaker 1: No, I know personally, I don't believe.
Speaker 4: So. Got you. Yup. David,
it's been a pleasure. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: Louis My pleasure is all on
this side of the microphone, my
friend. I really appreciate that